what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
it's been a while
but we gotta talk about venom two
because we have yet to get the teaser
trailer for it
and it's actually weird to think that
this thursday is going to be
a year since we received the title and
that tiny little
tiny little teaser they gave us we won't
call it a teaser but
it's been a year since we've really
heard anything at all but we have some
reports from a reliable
source and some rumors stating that it's
going to be this month and it could
actually be tomorrow or thursday so it
looks like the venom trailer could be
just
around the corner and i'll explain
everything that you need to know in this
video
but first be sure to subscribe so you
can stay up to date on all of the latest
mcu news and i'm giving away a captain
america shield giveaway details are in
the description down below the giveaway
ends at the end of this month
so to start this video off daniel rpk
daniel richman has stated that the venom
trailer is going
to come this month i actually know
daniel and any time that he's talked
about a trailer releasing he's been
right
his track record is really good so i
would say that there's a good chance
that we will get the venom trailer this
month
now today somebody posted anonymously of
course
on 4chan that the trailer is actually
going to come tomorrow
now of course i know that it's hard to
trust somebody just posting anonymously
online but
tomorrow actually is andy circus's
birthday the director
of venom 2. and if you happen to notice
yesterday
they actually released the trailer for
shang chi on sima liu's birthday
so if you take the combination of daniel
richmond stating that the trailer is
going to come this month
and the fact that tomorrow is andy
circus's birthday then maybe we
actually might get the trailer for venom
to let there be carnage tomorrow now i
want to state that this is not confirmed
we've had a lot of run-ins in the past
with us thinking that the trailer is
going to come out fake reports fake
photoshops so let's not get our hopes up
too much
but i will also say this we only have
5 months until venom let there be
carnage comes out and that is typically
when marvel and sony would drop a
trailer
and again daniel richmond is usually
right on trailers so there is a good
chance that it will come out this month
or very soon
or possibly even tomorrow also thursday
is definitely another option as i
mentioned in the beginning it's the one
year we'll call it an anniversary since
they gave us the
teaser where they revealed that the
title is going to be venom
let there be carnage so thursday is a
big possibility as well
now as far as what we're going to see i
would really hope that they would show
carnage if they don't show carnage i'm
going to be kind of disappointed
i don't have any doubts that they're
going to show cletus cassidy but i
really hope they show
carnage it's probably going to be just a
little bit of a tease not too much
but just give us enough to see what he's
going to look like because we
don't really have any photos leaked
anything of him yet but hopefully the
trailer does come tomorrow if not
thursday if not
very very soon so be sure to subscribe
and hit that notification bell so you
don't miss out when the venom 2
let there be carnage trailer drops be
sure to let me know how excited you are
for
the venom 2 trailer in the comments down
below and let me know what you think
we'll see
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof